[Music]
Mr snow
after everything you've seen out there
in the world
[Music]
what are the Hunger Games for
coming
The Hunger Games they're to punish the
districts those tributes don't have a
choice
Your Role is to turn these children into
spectacles not survivors
we're lives
smile it's why we have teeth
I just want to know that somebody still
cared about me that I was still a value
welcome to the capital you look like you
shouldn't be here I shouldn't but I'm
your Mentor a rebel
I'm gonna get you out of here
we want to protect people
and it's essential to accept what human
beings are
what it takes to control them
use that famous snow charm
you seem like a good man Carlina snow I
have seen what war does to people
filled with the turf becoming prey
see how quickly we become predator
I want my enemies to see a rainbow of
Destruction
engulfing the world
good luck with that poor little Songbird
where is she
mystery and Mysteries have a way of
driving people
no let me ask you one final time what
are the Hunger Games for
[Music]
it's the things we love most and destroy
us
[Music]